on the island of gotland they're
training for war
sweden is building its defenses
new weapons for an old enemy
putin has clearly shown his intent and
his will to use military force in order
to gain his political goals
we had a plan to increase the military
capability on the island
for a long time but since the invasion
we try to do it a lot faster
the war in ukraine has radically altered
sweden's security policy
pushing it from neutral to nato
after 200 years of military
non-alignment many soldiers here think
it's time to join the alliance
nato gives
high security measures
it's more likely we can keep the peace
here in europe
so i think it's a really really great
for both sweden and europe and nato that
sweden joins nato
times are changing in sweden in the next
few years they hope to be able to
mobilize more than 4 000 troops from
here in gotland and add weapons
including anti-ship missiles to their
arsenal
now a popular tourist spot gotland has
always played a key role in sweden's
defense they started the project in 1939
and most of the bunkers were done by
1940. world war ii bunkers litter the
island
and how many of these are there on the
island 1200 built
perhaps 1
900 still standing
why is this island so important for
defence
it's a question of where it is located
there you have gotland in the middle of
the baltic
less than 100 kilometers to the swedish
mainland say 150 to the baltic states
and then down here of course you have
kaliningrad the russian enclave it is
this perfect place in the middle and
with the good garrison
and the anti-aircraft and the shipping
missiles i mean you control the southern
baltic
but sweden has long portrayed itself as
a peacekeeper and some on the island
have red lines when it comes to nato
the military okay the nuclear no
because i don't like nuclear in any form
either weapon or craft station
but russian aggression has reset the
rules
neutrality is no longer an option here
sweden is re-learning how to be a
military power
siobhan robbins sky news